[Musique]
bienvenue dans le monde du futur paris
saclay tv vous transporte à des carbo
night city le jumeau numérique de votre
territoire non ce n'est pas de la
science fiction cette réplique virtuelle
de l'agglomération paris saclay permet
une meilleure transition énergétique
on vous explique tout dans un instant
l'énergie justement avec une nouvelle
expérimentation pour maîtriser la
consommation du chauffage le campus
urbain est un site pilote pour des tours
bridge ce projet européen vise à
développer les réseaux de chaleur et de
froid cinquième génération et bientôt
vous pourrez vous laisser conduire par
des véhicules autonome oui laissez vous
tenter par cette expérience renault
groupe cherche des testeurs enfin a
vivement le 21 juin c'est la fête de la
musique c'est aussi l'inauguration du
pavillon 1 réciproque vous avez
peut-être contribué à ce chantier
participatif c'est un lieu éphémère un
lieu de rencontre et pour découvrir
d'autres lieux et vivre d'autres
événements et bien ne ratez pas notre
agenda c'est à la fin cette émission
saviez vous que paris saclay avec son
jumeau numérique des carbonates city
c'est son nom est une réplique virtuelle
de l'agglomération de paris saclay cet
outil technologique permet d'anticiper
de twister et donc de mieux maîtriser la
performance énergétique d'un bâtiment
d'un quartier ou même d'un projet
d'aménagement beaucoup plus complexe
alors pour comprendre comment ça marche
regardez ce reportage
[Musique]
les carbonates city c'est un jumeau
numérique simula bhl qui est une
expérimentation qui est fait sur le
territoire de l'agglomération paris
saclay qui nous permet de numériser tout
notre territoire pour pouvoir
expérimenter des scénarios énergétiques
c'est comme un grand jeu vidéo un grand
sim city qui nous permet d'avoir des
simulations des estimations et pouvoir
voir au cas par cas quels sont les choix
énergétiques les plus pertinents pour
notre territoire
des carbone city c'est une innovation
technologique inédite en france et en
europe c'est le fruit de la
collaboration entre trois acteurs très
complémentaires l'agglomération
paris-saclay pionnière sur les questions
environnementales et deux spécialistes
en modélisation simulation et aide à la
décision pour les systèmes complexes
cosmo tech leader des jumeaux numérique
si minable et l'institut de recherche
technologique systemx
des carbone city permet aux décideurs
publics d'imaginer différents scénarios
possibles pour les futurs aménagements
énergétique du territoire et d'en
comparer leur impact carbone dans les
années à venir toutes les organisations
les entreprises les territoires auront
besoin de ce type d'outils afin
d'optimiser leurs investissements et
démontrer les performances
environnementales
des carbone city est la preuve que nous
savons les outiller et les aider dans
leur prise de décision
pour aller plus loin systémique prépare
un programme structurant avec tous ses
partenaires qui souhaitent maîtriser la
conception le déploiement et
l'évaluation des jumeaux numérique
simula bhl pour la digitalisation des
entreprises des services et des
territoires
une des applications concrètes c'est
lorsqu'une ville décide de développer un
nouveau quartier on peut se poser la
question de quel la bonne manière de
raccorder ce quartier à l'énergie est ce
que on prévoit de l'énergie renouvelable
et d'énergie renouvelable quel type
d'énergie renouvelable est ce qu'on va
attraper un réseau de chaleur à côté ce
qu'on va faire la géothermie est ce
qu'on va mettre du solaire ce jumeau
numérique cela permet en quelques clics
et de manière très simple d'avoir cette
simulation est de trouver le scénario
énergétique le plus performant cette
composante énergétique c'est la première
qui est développé sur ce jeu mou
numérique mais on peut imaginer bien
évidemment de nouveaux scénarios que ce
soit des scénarios de mobilité des
scénarios de logements des scénarios
d'évolution de météo etc voilà c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement ouvert qui
permet aux décideurs publics de pouvoir
prendre de bonnes décisions
[Musique]
la transition énergétique passe aussi
par le chauffage le campus urbain est un
site pilote du projet européen des
tigres ips ce programme ambitieux vise à
développer les réseaux de chaleur et de
froid cinquième génération aujourd'hui
une nouvelle expérimentation est en
cours elle se passe dans 70 logements
étudiants notamment ici sur cette
résidence universitaire l'objectif c'est
de piloter à distance
le chauffage la consommation de
chauffage via le contrôleur stormont
le réseau des changes de chaleur et
trois de paris saclay alimente la
majorité des bâtiments du campus urbain
de paris saclay et c'est également un
des sites pilotes du projet européen des
touristes ce qui est un projet qui vise
à développer les réseaux de chaleur et
de froid de cinquième génération en
europe dans le cadre du projet et des
souris tu le paies à paris saclay met
actuellement en oeuvre un démonstrateur
de gestion avancée de la demande
thermique l'objectif est d'apporter
flexibilité thermique au réseau en
diminuant les consommations énergétiques
et par là même en diminuant les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
cette première expérimentation vise à
équiper environ 70 logements étudiants
du campus de vannes thermostatiques
connecter sans fil ses 21 ans statique
seront couplées à des répéteurs qui
permettront de communiquer les données
de consommation énergétique des gens
auraient cliente équipés à un contrôleur
qui est contrôleur qui s'appelle le
contrôleur storm et qui a été développé
par point de nos partenaires du projet
des twins vitaux
ce contrôleur storm permet ainsi d'avoir
un pilotage à distance et permettra
d'avoir une gestion plus fine des
besoins et des consommation en chauffage
par deux moyens le premier c'est que les
usagers vont pouvoir contrôler à
distance la température de consigne de
l'eau de leur logement à une application
dédiée et dans un second temps pourra
également obtenir à distance les
informations de consommation sur la
consommation sur les données de
consommation
des chambres équipées cela va permettre
d'abaisser les pics de consommation
lorsque cela est nécessaire sans pour
autant diminuer le confort des chambres
équipées pour cette expérimentation nous
ça nous a accompagnés de plusieurs
partenaires et de diverses associations
étudiantes dont l'association impact et
l'association via un réseau qui se sont
notamment occupé du recrutement des
étudiants de volontaires participer à
l'expérimentation le cesal qui est le
gestionnaire des résidences étudiantes a
également participé à l'expérimentation
[Musique]
vous aussi vous avez envie de plonger
dans cet univers 2.0 alors pourquoi ne
pas devenir testeur de véhicule autonome
depuis quelques semaines renault groupe
expérimente sur le plateau de saclay des
services de mobilité à la demande une
voiture qui vous conduit toute seule
vous avez envie d'essayer et bien c'est
à vous de jouer
[Musique]
bienvenue à paris saclay autonomous
laddh notre expérimentation de services
de mobilité autonome à la demande
électrique et partager
cette expérimentation fait partie du
programme national sam evra sam evra
pour sécurité et acceptabilité de la
conduite autonome et de la mobilité
autonome
l'objectif est de faire bénéficier notre
expérimentation à plus de 250
utilisateurs que nous avons recruté pour
faire partie d'un panel afin de
comprendre et d'apprendre d'eux
d'apprendre de leur retour d'expérience
et puis de comprendre aussi à quel point
notre proposition est adapté aux besoins
du territoire et aux besoins en termes
de mobilité notamment
d'un utilisateur vous montez à bord de
nos eaux et cab qui sont sur des bases
de zoé de série agrémenté de capteurs
qui permettent à la voiture d'être
autonome à l'intérieur nous avons un
ingénieur d'essais qui vérifie la
qualité du système est un opérateur de
sécurité derrière le volant à prendre en
main en cas de situation non gérer car
même si nos prototypes sont autonomes la
sécurité passe avant tout
j'ai postulé sur sur le site on va
envoyer une réponse comme quoi gt gt
prix entre guillemets ça m'a intéressé
je me suis dit que ça pouvait me
permettre de faire les trajets du rer
jusqu'à l'école et ça pouvait être
pratique ce serait plus rapide
c'est assez impressionnant de voir une
voiture se déplacer seules sont sans
l'assistance d'un humain
je suis en école d'ingénieur je fais un
cursus data science donc je fais
beaucoup d'intelligence artificielle
donc c'est un peu un peu mon domaine
c'est un projet sur lequel je pourrais
être amené par exemple à travailler et
donc il y avait ça aussi qui a fait que
ben ça ça m'a intéressé je voulais voir
un petit peu comment ça se passe et voir
de l'intérieur comment une voiture
autonome marché quoi c'est une
expérience intéressante à vivre
[Musique]
certains d'entre vous ont peut-être co
construit ce pavillon réciproque a lieu
éphémère un lieu de rencontre voulue par
le pea paris saclay un pavillons encore
inachevés
alors laissez vous tenter pourquoi ne
pas participer à ce chantier
participatif
une deuxième phase des travaux est prévu
en mai avant l'inauguration le 21 juin
jour de fête de la musique
nous sommes sur le chantier du pavillon
réciproque le pavillon réciproque donc
les construit par le pea paris-saclay
sur la place marguerite perret où nous
sommes qui constitue l'espace public
principale du quartier l'école
polytechnique on a fait le constat en
fait partager avec l'ensemble des
usagers que le campus manqué de lieux un
peu neutre qui soit pas rattachés à une
entreprise ou à une école ou un
établissement et donc on avait ce besoin
en fait de construire des lieux qui
puisse accueillir les différents publics
et qu'ils puissent être à la disposition
de tout le monde et on puisse constituer
des lieux de rencontre et donc nous
avons décidé de construire ce pavillon
qui en fait un pavillon temporaire c'est
à dire qu' il va être démontée d'ici
deux à trois ans on a également souhaité
que ce pavillon soit construit dans le
cadre d'un chantier participatif ça veut
dire que les constructeurs le groupement
depuis 1920 quidam et 14 qui sont
spécialisés et dans la construction bois
et dans l'organisation de chantier
participatif
ouvre certaines parties du chantier à la
co-construction avec les usagers donc
concrètement on a lancé un appel à
l'ensemble des personnes qui composent
le campus de pouvoir revenir sur
certaines plages horaires nous aider ce
chantier participatif s'achève là donc
il a duré 15 jours et on a un prochain
chantier participatif qui va se dérouler
du 2 au 6 mai pour construire ce qu'on
appelle le lanterneau qui va être en
fait un petit édifice en bois qui va
surmonter le pavillon dans sa forme
finale
et on est très fiers de participer à ce
projet et sous le triptyque et des
bénévoles ce projet et partager nos
savoir faire autour des constructions
bois donc sur ce projet au bout d'une
semaine à dix jours maintenant on a eu
des profils des bénévoles très diverses
avec qui on a passé de très bons moments
de partage de convivialité et aussi de
transmission qui est très important pour
nous de faire participer les gens dans
le processus de construction et
et partager cette moment merveilleux
voilà
le pavillon réciproque sera ouvert à
l'ensemble des usagers du campus soit
sous forme de location soit sous forme
de mise à disposition il sera inauguré
le 21 juin donc j'invite tous ceux qui
souhaitent venir à l'occasion de la fête
de la musique assisté à l'inauguration
du pavillon est donc ce sera l'occasion
de tester pour la première fois le
pavillon et notamment en accueillant des
groupes de musique issus des
associations enfin du tissu associatif
étudiants du campus mais également avec
un certain nombre d'ateliers en
collaboration avec la ville de palaiseau
et en particulier le service jeunesse et
le service culture
[Musique]
notre agenda à présent on vient d'en
parler il faut terminer le pavillon
réciproque alors pourquoi ne pas
participer au chantier c'est du 2 au 6
mai de 13h30 à 16h30 l'événement de ce
mois de mai vous le savez c'est le paris
saclay et spring vous pouvez encore vous
inscrire découvrez le programme et les
intervenants sur le site qui s'affiche
sur votre écran rendez vous est pris les
12 et 13 mai c'est à l'école
polytechnique et enfin la nuit
européenne des musées c'est le 14 le
mieux est de vous propose une soirée
exceptionnelle avec le musée de la ville
alors au programme karaoké soirée pyjama
atelier just dance fresque jeu
projection et j'en passe donc ne ratez
pas ce beau rendez vous culturel voilà
c'est déjà la fin de cette émission
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de paris saclay tv
[Musique]